I'm John King guard CEO of king-sized
bows incorporated and welcome to my bow
Kingdom we're in the joy business we
make special occasions special I have to
say that our most popular bow is our
signature monarch fold the red and
silver one
the Lexus commercials that we've had the
privilege of doing for the last eight
years has really drawn attention to the
multi loop bows we're the only ones in
the United States who actually make
those bows we make them out of a variety
of fabrics and textures and those are
the ones that people are most interested
in there's a whole bow language that
most people don't speak but there are
definitely differences of opinions about
how many loops how long the tails should
be and whether there's a V cut or an
angled cut we are pleased to be in every
showroom from Ferrari to the mini to the
Ford to BMW now we found that customers
really expect to keep the bow when they
buy the car they want to drive away with
the bow you'd be surprised where people
put bows it's not just on top of a car
anyplace that you want to say look at me
look at me it can be on a bicycle or a
surfboard or skis on a gate on the top
of your house at a pinnacle
once you put a bow on it it's a present